every single person here has probably
missed out on the best thing that ever
could have happened to them in their
lives and the second you accept that
truth that the millions of decisions
you've already made in your life have
probably kept you away from the best
thing that could have ever happened in
your life the love of your life the idea
of your life business oper the money
made like all of it then I think you can
start leaning Into The Human Experience
we don't give ourselves enough room and
it goes back to patience how do you do
both by knowing you have a lot of time
to do both and as far as fomo you're
never going to know how it would have
been anyway plus the thing I always
think about to make myself feel even
better about the fact that I've said no
to the best things that ever could have
happened to me is knowing that it also
would have changed the course of my life
so yes maybe I would have said yes to
going out with my friends this night and
I would have saw something and it would
have led to the idea of my life but
maybe then while I was executing that
idea something bad could have happened
attention is the number one
asset first of all it's such a pleasure
it's good to see everybody you know 14
years ago my brother and I started a
company so not too around the same range
as you guys and the goal was to be able
to effectively communicate everywhere in
the world at that point in my life when
I was 13 14 years ago when I was
3334 I had a sense that I finally
started to understand what I was good at
i' you know built my family's uh retail
business up and I realized I loved the
marketing more than selling the product
and and I was very good at it and I was
doing things early I was doing you know
I did e-commerce in
1996 you know majority of this room
wasn't born in 1996 I was doing email
marketing in 1999 when I could get 90%
of the people on the email list to open
the email I bought Google AdWords the
day the day Google AdWords started I
started a long form YouTube show in
February of 2006 you know I was an early
investor in Facebook and Twitter I was
there and and so I wanted to start a
Communications infrastructure because I
wanted it to be at my disposal I thought
of it as the most important remote
control of my life that whatever
business I started whatever uh things I
was passionate about uh if I wanted I
always kind of knew myself so I said you
know if I'm 84 years old and somebody I
love is taken by a disease I'm going to
want to cure that disease and yeah I
could raise money but that's been proven
to me as not the most effective way the
most effective way is to get the world
to care and I figured if I could build a
Communications infrastructure sure
whether I wanted to sell sneakers or I
wanted to cure diseases and everything
in between that that would be important
as my remote control and so I started
that company 14 years ago and slowly but
surely we're building enough scale that
we able to expand into other places I've
been doing personal content for a long
time I was very early Snapchat I've
always had a pretty strong you know
presence uh among Snapchat users in
Saudi cuz I was pretty early making
content so I've always wanted to get
here as you know I've been to the
overall middle east region a lot we've
tried to get here multiple times I'm
always very in andout I leave tomorrow
like I just got here you know um so I'm
just very excited to be here and
obviously I don't have to tell anybody
in this room it has been remarkable to
watch the expansion of opportunity and
creativity and growth in this country in
the last 12 to 18 months and I can't
even wrap my head around what the next
decade looks like and so you know the
way I talk about Africa the way I think
about Korea there's just certain parts
that I am interested in investing more
time into because I haven't fully gotten
in uh in there yet because I think you
can't story tell unless you respect and
listen and so before I think about those
things I want to spend a lot of time
doing those things and so I'm excited to
be here well you know it's uh it's
definitely a pleasure having you here
and uh it's a it's an honor of course I
want to ask you a question if you don't
um you know uh it seems like a lot of
your success um and from what you what
you just said happened because of
because you're an earlier ad doctor you
made right decisions with Right company
right Investments early on um had words
when it first came out you that you made
content before people started making
content uh you on YouTube you are um you
invested in Facebook and how how did you
make these decisions what helped you
make these right decisions I think two
things when I think about it cuz it's
the thing that people ask me the most
about and and I've spent a good last 10
years trying to understand it I think
there's a lot of things that worked out
for me one um I'm incredibly curious I
didn't it wasn't something I really knew
about myself but especially when it
comes to people you know I could have
like you know a very different true
answer to my last question is because I
genuinely like people and I'd like to
meet them all and I think the only way
you can do that is if you go and so
I I've always had a very strong
curiosity of people even as a child 7 8
10 years old I was disproportionately
the kid in the class that had the most
friends I wanted to be friends with
everyone I was interested in everyone I
liked everyone and so curiosity about
people has always been a thing on top of
that I've always been a Salesman I
always wanted to sell candy or lemonade
or trading cards and so if you're going
to sell you have to pay attention so I
think
the things that work for me is I'm
curious about
people I'm I'm very willing to waste
time this is a big one I think one of
the reasons I'm good at what I do is I'm
willing to waste time so I'm curious I
see something what I saw six years ago
musically so I see musically and I see
wow it's a very young social network and
it's mainly 13-year-old girls right now
and they're dancing but what I saw
because I spent 20 hours on it at a time
when people as busy as me wouldn't spend
2 minutes on it cuz they would dismiss
it was huh I think the music and the app
is making it easier for these young
girls to make content as you know as all
of you know anything that makes it
easier for people to make content is
always powerful it's like training
wheels when you learn to ride a bike so
I was able to through my curiosity which
is why I even saw music Al but then my
humility of my own time I think too many
people value their time too much when
it's not that
valuable people get fancy they're like
I'm too busy I'm like no you're not
you're too lazy you're too Cur you're
too lack of curiosity you're too uh
audacious you're too complacent you're
too passive I none of those things apply
to me when it comes to business and so I
think I use those things and then the
other thing is I am not this would be
interesting in a room full of smart
creatives the only thing I have
conviction
about is that y'all are right and I'm
not the only thing I have conviction of
is that the audience and humans are more
right than me I think one of the
challenges with very creative people or
very ambitious people is you have strong
opinions which are quite powerful right
the ability to say no or to have
conviction is incredibly powerful I do
think a lot of people miss out on
opportunity because they don't have the
humility to understand the audience is
more right than
them and so it's a very fine balance of
having conviction of what you see
especially creatively but also
respecting and for you and for a lot of
you when you're native YouTube when
you're native social it's a lot more
interesting because you can't hide the
results speak you know when you do a
commercial in television the things we
both agree on are dead well you can hide
behind the Press saying it was a good
commercial or you getting an award right
but actual consumption in Social and
digital numbers don't lie numbers don't
lie and so I think that my level of
humility to me I think regardless of how
successful I've been for the last 30
years of my career tomorrow can become
the day that it starts declining if I
don't stay humble and curious and uh I
focus on that I'm also not romantic
about how I make I'm not attached to how
I'm making my money
now so if Netflix and YouTube and Tik
Tok are important to me today I'm always
ready for them not to be important
tomorrow even if that means that I might
have to take a step back financially in
the short term I think the biggest thing
that hurts people is they get stuck on
how they make their money and then
they're not willing to deviate and
follow the consumer they're following
their comfort and their
wallet I was going to say uh one of the
things that you have been very effective
at is you you really focus G on uh pop
culture yes like how to be relevant in
culture and pop culture TZ also I saw is
very strong they started their company
C3 creative culture cat culture Catalyst
because they believe that if they're not
being a catalyst for culture and
relevant to public culture so you both
have that in common why is pop culture
so important to your
DNA I think it's this I think it's
potentially the most significant
currency that lives in the world you
know I I said I I almost said it was and
then you know you know me well enough
I'm a pretty big fan of love so I think
I'll put love ahead of it but gez the
fact that pop culture is very close to
love when I think about the currency of
the world you know I I think I think
it's incredibly naive to not make a huge
commitment to popular
culture to me I you know it's really
funny it's almost like saying like why
is water and oxygen important that's
like when you ask the question I'm
almost struggling to articulate I I'm
I'm shocked that 99% of the world
continues to not see this like why is he
wearing Vans why is he wearing Air Force
Ones why why why everything is so
important
and it's so obvious um I think it you
know even when you go out to dinner the
friend that knows the emerging you know
artist of music or is most on top of why
people are wearing a certain fashion I
think about everything like even when I
sit in an audience like this I'm
analyzing like the denim jacket or what
the hairstyles are like it everything
matters to me everything because we all
make decisions we don't think about it
but everyone here literally is
subconsciously making decisions on what
they're wearing headphones around the
neck this is all profound to me it's
profound to me it's how the world works
and so I spend an uncanny amount of time
trying to stay on top of which artist
and and here's why what's really cool
about pop culture is it's like
cooking pop culture is like cooking you
know why cooking is fascinating we can
all have the same ingredients here right
but the way we all cook it would be
different and some would be delicious
and some would not I think the most
interesting thing about pop culture is
vans vans originally were really made
for California surf and skateboard kids
but then with the way the way pop
culture works all of a sudden black kids
in the ghetto started wearing it as a
cool thing and I remember watching that
and look look what's even happening
right now like I'm literally getting
Goosebumps look at this as I'm talking
here's why the manipulation like
ingredients like cells coming together
of pop culture is the most interesting
thing in the world something starts as
something it's why I love people in the
world it's why I love what the world's
doing now all of our grandparents lived
in a world where the way media was they
told us how to feel about each other the
world used to tell us how to think about
each other now because of the way
content works we can discover each other
for what it is
I love that that's the world that's
chemicals that's the fusion I'm talking
about there's nothing more interesting
into why something becomes
popular and you know this things that
become popular today 20 years ago were
inconceivable and and in 20 years things
that we find popular today or how we
everybody will look at photos of the way
they look right now in 20 years and
laugh at what they were wearing
hairstyles it's just amazing to me and
so I keep a real attention on that
because I like how things come together
and create something new so speaking of
things that you know uh becoming popular
and how things become popular um and you
spoke on on content and listening to the
audience and that's one of the most
important things when creating content
what's your take on creating something
new creating new trends um you know
giving the audence something they didn't
know they needed well I think that that
is a ever game that humans are
incredibly capable of this is why we're
such a superior species to a worm or a
bird we have that incredible creative
power I believe it is a huge to me and I
love the way you're asking that question
when I'm paying attention to things I
don't think that that curtails my
ability to do something new I think it
empowers
it because the reality is something new
has always been motivated by something
in the past right but we are individual
humans with our individual experiences
and laying at night and in the shower
thinking and brush you know it's amazing
how that works so I think it's the most
true thing but I love when people are
like this person's you know somebody
like this person a Movie Maker an artist
an athlete they're like this is an
original and I think about it ah let me
give you a very interesting way to
answer this question how do I think
about it there's a documentary I think
all of you should watch about Little
Richard Little Richard is a very famous
musician
if you go into it you'll basically leave
watching the documentary thinking and
being completely affected by and and
this has been long believed by many
people who are passionate about music
that Little Richard is truly the father
of rock and roll okay this black man
from Georgia truly and you'll watch it
that the Rolling Stones and Elvis
there's unlimited content showing them
saying I was in inspired by Little
Richard however so this whole movie is a
documentary about Little Richard it's
filled with unlimited content from David
Bowie to MC Jagger to Elvis Presley
saying to you know to to The Beatles
Little Richard right it's clearly a pro
pro Little Richard is the king of rock
and roll and how does the movie start in
the first 13 15 minutes of the film 20
minutes of the film talking about his
childhood it literally shows you the 11
people that impacted him to be become
him it was very small it's back to the
thing I talked about they were very
small ingredients and he had his own DNA
his own life the timing right timing is
everything I have a funny feeling your
wrestling film acts very differently 20
years earlier because the country was in
just a different world the world's
different the distribution's different
you don't even get it made a year
earlier right right so I think what's
really powerful of how I think about
that that is that's how the world will
always work right and so even though I'm
listening to the comments I'm I get a
lot of credit for doing a lot of
original things when I broke out in my
industry I was so in wine in America I
was so like he's so different I would
watch it back to wrestling I was like
wait a minute I'm different and I also
love standup comment actually two things
we just talked about I was so affected
by Richard prior and Eddie Murphy and by
Randy the Macho Savage the wrestler that
my communication style you know I didn't
realize it but then like 10 years later
I'm like wait a minute this I you know
and so it's clearly not me doing them
it's it's their little seeds are in me
and then there's 90% me and that's how I
think original thoughts get done I think
and just building on the question too
like they put out content movies TV
shows that type of thing and people are
used to a certain thinking go f so they
don't want to just do what the consumers
want they want to create for they're not
creating for the market they're creating
for themselves I think that's right I I
think that I think that's right comma
back to popular culture or listening if
you're doing an hour 30 film and you
decided you're going to do it about this
subject matter that none of the comments
have told you that you wanted however in
the writing or in the Improv of the
acting or in the directing or producing
of the film if you're making three to
four references from things that you
know are happening in popular culture
it's going to land that's exactly what
we did and so I think of that as like
right there you go so I think of that as
taking advantage of what you do what
they do for a living and doing so much
content and understanding pop culture
but when they go to a bigger production
like they've done it's using those
elements as spices and side dishes not
the main meal because they the main dish
is what they wanted to make I would like
everyone in the audience to get a chance
to ask Gary something I if you have
other questions feel
free do it together anyone want to ask
something how to fight the feeling of
impatience when you have too many plans
thank you for asking me that it's you're
you're right it's my number one it's my
number one it's my number one it's my
number one because it goes back to
listening 30% of my hundreds of
thousands of direct messages that I get
a year uh if not Millions at this point
are based on this you know look I think
there's a couple things even the way you
set the story to your point one of the
things that I know is that the
generation of parents that parented you
and definitely their parents and on and
on the there is an
overvaluing of status and profession as
something that those parents brag to
their friends and their parents about so
you have an entire generation of Asian
and brown kids and Eastern European kids
who are pushed who are pushed very
heavily into engineering into medicine
into law into the cliche things and so
this is pounded into people's heads what
I believe that does is creates an
incredible vulnerability for those kids
to resent their parents to not be happy
and that's why I produce so much content
about that what it also does is when you
were a student you were on a track
you're a robot you go up every year you
get grades you go up you go to you go to
bigger School higher School University
it it's it's a fake game life is a real
game life is a real game so people are
impatient because the first 18 22 years
of their life every year they move up a
level it's just it's like playing a
video game then you get to real life and
real life is not linear like that and
those kids even though they might have
resentment or anger or have reconciled
with their parents about out don't worry
about other people's opinions you just
want me to be a doctor because your
sister your best friend meanwhile they
themselves are worried about other
people's opinions there is no reason to
be impatient if you are learning every
day and feel like you're on the right
track the only thing that can dictate
that is outside forces right because the
reality is if you're happy and you feel
like you're learning every day and
you're on the right track the only other
parts of the world are outside opinions
and the things that you physically want
do you want a Lamborghini do you want a
nice apartment do you want a watch my
argument is the faster you can get away
from wanting physical items and wanting
validation from other human beings that
are not living your life the quicker you
lack the ability to be
impatient you have to ask yourself and I
believe the reason people want things 95
5% of the time is for outside
validation I'm not so sure that people
want a Porsche for the Porsche or for
what people think about them when they
have a Porsche and so I'm very
passionate about outside voices I think
if you you know when I hear your story
of like you wanted to do this then you
were pushed this way now you found
yourself back and you're this young and
I know that people that are 27 don't
think they're young because 27 you're
starting to smell 30 and when you're 20
30 feels super
world my cousin my cousin worked for my
father when I finished University I was
22 he was 30 and that I remember the
first day I walked into the store and
I've been working with him for a long
time but I remember when I was 22 and he
was 30 I thought he was a thousand 30
when you're 22 how old are you my
friend how old 25 when you're 25 when
you're 23 when you're 22 30 feels like
it feels like a big number but when
you're 47 you know how laughable that is
because at 47 I feel 25 I feel ex I
remember 25 like yesterday it was the
year 2000 um I had to go to the store
and make sure Y2K didn't break the
computers I remember the day I was his
age and when I tell you inside my
stomach inside my soul inside my
ambition inside my dreams and hopes and
wants I feel exactly like he does so you
can imagine how not worried I am at 27
but you have to start genuinely looking
yourself in the mirror and asking how
much of your impatience is predicated on
outside opinions and I would argue
almost all of it when I see others
succeeding I ask myself why am I not at
that place yet you have the wrong
definition of success let me explain
what I mean by that I think you're right
but I would also ask you if you're in
the process of accomplishing that you're
actually in the best
place the process of accomplishing it is
often better than accomplishing it
I would argue for people that have
pulled off making films that if we
really ask them the day of the seed of
the idea is even more exciting than the
day it airs when you a maker the process
is more enjoyable making it like as a
matter of fact almost all of my most
challenging days is when something I was
excited about has been
finished many think it's the day it's
when you sell it it's when it happens
it's when you're awarded it's not the
fun part I understand you want to make a
movie it makes sense I'm just asking you
you don't know anything about that
person's
Journey you're making assumptions and
more importantly you need to figure out
here's a good one this is a very unique
take on what you're saying I'm curious
if this is going to bring you value I'm
going to go in a very interesting place
Dustin you've never heard this from me
it's something I've been thinking a lot
about I've always been fascinated by
perfectionism you know people are like
I'm I'm a per Gary you don't get it I'm
a perfectionist and I always knew that
wasn't true I always knew that it was
insecurity that they were scared to put
it out that's why they were using per
but but be but saying you're
insecure is not as cool as saying you're
a
perfectionist but it was the same game
I've always been fascinated by people
who position themselves as being tough
in themselves especially when they are
quick to bring out that everybody around
them always says that they're too tough
on themselves because it means they've
been effectively storytelling to the
people around them that they're too hard
of themselves which is actually a very
on paper admirable kind of positioning I
would I would ask yourself when you go
to sleep tonight and you think about
this are you interested in positioning
yourself to the people around you as
someone who is hard in themselves or are
you hard in yourself do you understand
it's it's interesting work yeah look
inside you have to look inside because I
think it's a smart way to position
yourself as a protection mechanism to
give you time on your journey so you're
not judged while you're on your
journey I thought you would I like it
too it's something I've been thinking
about anyone else have a question for
please please sometimes people get
intimidated by my facial expressions do
you have any advice on how to approach
that yeah so let me think a couple
things one on the second one it's you
know I love that you are aware of
that all you need to do is act on that
empathy and insight meaning if you are
quick to physically react if somebody's
throwing an idea and you're like or like
whatever it may
be if you feel like that's detrimental
to you and I'm sure you're you're a
human being you also want to be
empathetic to how it makes the other
person feel you just need to be on the
off offense to communicate the context
meaning one thing I do a lot I'm also
very intuitive very quick if I feel like
I react to something and I can tell that
it does not land I will immediately
recontextualize it in the moment I think
you need to use your
words I think you need to use your words
your words will offset your face but you
have to be active on it you have to
acknowledge if if you're if you're
recognizing that you need to be
aggressive about that especially when
you know you're thinking the opposite
the first thing I would tell you to do
is when you're feeling the opposite uh
when you're positive about something
you're excited about that you can never
leave an interaction without without
overc communicating Your Enthusiasm
because that will then offset that
scenario look the first one to your
point how to lead conversation with
strict parents who don't support what
I'm doing the only thing that ever works
is understanding the to your point the
move out that's a Band-Aid get into a
fight with them that's a Band-Aid set
them straight that's a Band-Aid the only
thing I've ever seen really work in this
game is understanding the alternative
will create a worse relationship with
you and your parents meaning the biggest
challenge kids have that love their
parents or are frustrated with their
parents of not accepting their journey
is understanding that if they the child
compromises and appeases the parent
that within a decade you will have such
high levels of resentment towards your
parents that your relationship for the
rest of your lives will be negative and
so what you're deciding because you love
your parents is that you're willing to
Bear your teeth and grind it out and be
inconvenience and struggle with it in
the short term for the greater good
because in this scenario 50% of the time
it works out and parents always then
rewrite history and are very proud and
you know how it is and even if it
doesn't work out even if the child
that's on a journey does not
succeed they have put themselves in a
position to not blame their parents
because they gave it their full effort
and they'll never have that resentment
or regret so I think the answer to your
question is in your scenario where you
feel like you don't have a lot of
options and you're not going to change
their mind with words the only way
you're going to do it is by changing
their mind with actions it's just going
to take you 10 this goes into patience
it's just going to take you 10 years
and you have to in your mind go very
high level and say I'm willing for it to
not be ideal for the next three 5 10
years because if I quit this and do what
I want them to
do well there's no outcome that it's
going to be
healthy that was telling me the story
today about him and him and I started
creating content and they were like
sitting in the rooms and filming and
editing and doing these comedy shows and
their parents were like what are you
guys doing of course expected until the
content went viral on WhatsApp and then
the parents somebody shared it with the
parents and then he's like oh that's my
son who made that of course like I said
I saw Zach laughed parents are
incredible in rewriting history oh I've
always believed you can do
it you know it's look parents love their
CH as a parent you love your children so
much that it makes you delusional you
love them so much you love them so much
that you're not rational and parents do
overvalue other parents' opinions too
much that's why I hope this generation
all of you the biggest thing that
frustrates me is kids live it like
almost all your parents had the same
frustrations with their parents but then
they're doing it to you so don't do it
to your that's right my my hope is that
this generation becomes the generation
that isn't a
hypocrite breaks the cycle breaks the
cycle any other question questions how
can I figure out if I have the idea for
the next Mega hit yeah there there's
only two ways to do it one the way
they've always done it which is blind
conviction you don't know and you just
have this burning desire to tell the
story and you just got to go the new way
that we're all very fortunate to do is
there is subtle ways to play with it in
Social where you don't give it away but
you're able to thematically get a feel
if there's something that's resonating
and I think in reality everything in the
future given the structure we have is
going to look like a little bit of both
right like there's a reason many people
will do a little bit of both
um you know my team when I think about
my content Dustin's sitting here he
knows how true this is there are we have
a very good understanding of best
practices the first three seconds the
thumbnail what time to like we're very
much in the science of the art and we're
in the art of the art yet there are many
things things that I said here today
definitely what I said to you because
I've never said it before that when the
team will take the raw footage right now
and they'll clip it into best practices
so they'll try to edit what we just did
for a minute and I'll reply to the team
when they give it to me and say no no
that one was special to me play it and
it's full and it'll be 3 minutes and 19
seconds and I know that a lot of people
won't watch it I know that that video
will get 47,000 views instead of 800,000
but I don't care
cuz I want to say it got it and so you
know now there's there's a very
interesting line there of Commercial
Success right with like your own
passions you know you obviously get a
lot more freedom long term to do what
you want with commercial success but I
do think the way like you know when I
think about the exciting things I heard
about Cinema here and when I think about
what's going on with
Netflix I I think we could probably all
agree here we're probably not very far
away from and this has been flirted with
for a long time but I believe in the
next 15 years we will have a massive hit
of direct to Consumer movie that will
really transcend our industry I believe
someone that looks the profile of y'all
When I See This Crew I'm like okay
that's an evolution of what I see when I
go to Hollywood that's more blended into
what I believe in and what they're doing
it's a it's back to that blend right mhm
I think that somewhere in the next 15
years maybe maybe y'all or maybe an
evolution of what you're up to
somebody's going to sell 40 million
copies of a movie $9 on a website the
technology will be there that they could
actually get 40 million different people
like the things that we all know is like
the blockchain is going to be profound
the blockchain right now is confused
because of nfts and the scamming and all
but like the technology is profound for
what I just said that on the blockchain
versus the internet is a whole different
thing right because you can prove it
like there's just so many things going
augmented reality AI VR the Met like
there's a lot going on so I think that
we're all going to be able to be in a
place and I think you're going to end up
doing both I think every creative person
in in the future and starting now will
probably end up doing both doing some
stuff for commercial success and just
like I'm doing with my content many
things I do because I know it's going to
work and I believe in it and we'll do it
the best way we can and I'll get 4
million views but I'm very proud and I
show it to my team because I want them
to learn from me I'm like no no no I
know this is not going to do well but
for the seven people that I mean I know
the exchange you and I had about that
I'm too hard on myself that's a convers
because I study this stuff what I said
to you is not what people talk about
when they talk about that I know that
there's 29 people on Earth that are
going to watch that video and it's going
to start they're going to be ready to
hear that a 100 of them like no Gary cuz
they don't they're not ready right but
for the 29 that are ready and it's worth
it and I think that's how you have to
think about your sci-fi thing is this
something that that you can't go to the
ground in a 100 years God willing that
you never made it that you'll be
devastated or are you okay because you
got nine other stories that you're
equally Curious by those are things you
have to decide for yourself the film
industry in Saudi Arabia is just
starting is now the time to experiment
or to figure out how to build it I I
think they're one and the same okay
because I think what you're saying from
experimenting is really the thing that
fascinates all of us as storytellers
which
is do you know how many films were made
that had all the science and polling and
analytics behind it and
flopped math is not undefeated when it
has to dance with art you understand
math is undefeated when it plays with
itself but when it plays with art it can
lose too so I think what I would say is
on both of the ways you asked it both
should go as hard and as fast as it can
because this is unprecedented times
right whether you experiment or you go
with something tried and true or however
you define that the fact that you all
starting with the founders have put in
the 11 years relationships that were
formed before came together like look
it's really exciting for me who likes to
root for people to know the position
you're in at the time that you're in and
I think I think for all of you for all
of you the timing in this incredible
country in this genre is
unprecedented it's really special and so
I I think this is you don't want to do
what a lot of people end up doing which
is in 30 years realizing how
unprecedented it was and you're like why
did I leave at 6
o' and just go play video games like
this was the time I should have went as
hard as possible there will never be a
time like this again because people are
going to come like use this moment what
am I doing here people are going to
come this is an unprecedented time go as
hard as you
can so you said that you know maybe you
should have conviction for something if
you want to experiment you have hard
conviction you have scut feeling need it
needs to come out regardless of the
commercial
maybe um how can we make a maybe an
educated guest using you know living in
the in the social age where we're
connected where we
use data use
feedback how would
you yeah let's let's use the film that
you educated me on that did well there
is especially with your network and how
you understand it there was there's an
incredible opportunity for you to
disguise what you're working on yet
still talk about the genre of wrestling
and put that content into social with
not the same characters with not the
same stuff but you can actually get
validation to the interest around a
genre by putting it out there in
disguised form I do that quite a bit you
just could it's not a perfect
match but the reality is is you can you
really can you really can do clips and
little mini you know like you know um
one two three four minute clips that
play with the themes of the show or I'll
give you a good example maybe when you
were writing it you know I don't know
the film obviously but maybe there's a
big storyline of the relationship of the
wrestler with his grandmother I'm just
making that up well there's a lot of
ways you could do interesting social
content to 33 million people in this
country of of around relationships with
Uncle relationships with grandfather
relationships with grandmother and
actually look at the data and the
feedback and be like wait a minute
actually nobody's really talking about
the the uncle Dynamic and it seems like
that really caught a lot of people's
attention maybe let's rewrite it and
make it about the uncle's relationship
instead of the Grandma's that's how I
think it can affect it what to do if you
start losing your authenticity I love
that you know I've always felt that the
thing that helps me with that the most
is having the capacity to step
away and step away is not as literal as
you know moving out of a house or
stepping away it doesn't mean you have
to step away and go for six months to
the mountains and come back it means
stepping away in actually creating more
time for yourself to think and be around
the elements that were who you were I'll
give you an example with me when I feel
like I'm like a little bit more detached
from the center I tend to go back to
spending more times with my friends from
high school or college or starting to
narrow in my circle usually the reason
you're getting away from your authentic
place is the Human Relationships around
you and they don't even have to be bad
I'll give you a great example that might
be similar to yours I realized three and
a half years ago that I was getting
worse at marketing CU I hired too many
people from
agencies and even though I was the Alpha
and the CEO and dictating their energy
was starting to bleed into
me and so what did I do I made a big
to-do about it and said I'm not as good
as I used to be started spending more
time on my content started a I had the
power to do this started to trim out
some of the people that I thought were
bringing too much of the tradition in a
respectful nice way um I think you have
to protect your energy you have to
really no different than a lot of us
going through work you need to figure
out what in the job what in your
personal relationships what in the
content that you're consuming what in
the people that you're talking to who
who can you re [__] and how do you get
into that place you know like it it's
getting back to those roots I I think if
it's funny how you asked the question I
would spend as much time as possible on
who were you with and what were you
consuming at the time that you were like
the way you wish you were one of the
more interesting emails I get from
people that consume my content is titled
like I'm back with you now that I've
been doing it for a long time I get a
lot of people who say you know I I
stopped watching your content 5 years
ago and I've started consuming it again
6 months ago and it's really helping me
and it's a version of what I'm talking
to you about right now which was they
reset and tried to think about when they
were happier or when they were more what
they want to be what were they doing
what were they consuming and who were
they with and I think it's that's an
audit you need to
consider does that make sense in any
way it's it's hard you know the thing
that's hard for all of us is it's in the
subconscious but I I think that that's
what I would do if I was when I'm in a
rut I like that I try try to go back and
like I do funny things like I go garage
sailing um I remember one time
specifically I even worked in my dad's
store for a day just to like I I'm get
back to the I'm telling you I I know
it's I notice how I asked you does that
make sense I knew you were going to like
it's not easy what I'm saying but I do
think if you can go very
literal and say okay I was most
authentic sell phone I was watching
these kind of
videos because you can even though
you're a different man than you were 5
years ago 3 years ago you can start to
do that it's something worth thinking
about we have one last question and then
we need to want to give
a how do I balance seeking more
opportunities and striving toward my
number one goal I would say that every
single person in this room I'll let you
finish the second question but let me
jump on this one every single person
here has probably missed out on the best
thing that ever could have happened to
them in their
lives and the second you accept that
truth that the millions of decisions
you've already made in your life have
probably kept you away from the best
thing that could have ever happened in
your life the love of your life the idea
of your life the business Opera the
money make like all of it then I think
you can start leaning Into The Human
Experience I'm telling you that's what
it is like we we we don't give ourselves
enough room and it goes back to
patience like you know how do you do
both by knowing you have a lot of time
to do both and as far as fomo
you're never going to know how it would
have been anyway plus the thing I always
think about to make myself feel even
better about the fact that I've said no
to the best things that ever could have
happened to me is knowing that it also
would have changed the course of my life
so yes maybe I would have said yes to
going out with my friends this night and
I would have saw something and it would
have led to the idea of my life but
maybe then while I was executing that
idea something bad could have happened
maybe that would have brought me to a
meeting in LA and I wasn't paying
attention and a car hit me and I'd be
dead right right now I think people are
fascinating in their inability to
understand how much of life you don't
control and that like everything is
everything is
fomo you need to flip it instead of
think thinking of it literally you need
to think of it much bigger like that's
happening every day like every like do
you understand like you're thinking
about it as like should I go do this
project should I do this you're looking
at the big things I think it's even if
you left your house 5 minutes earlier
tomorrow your life would be different
it's really really big you know what I
mean like I know it may sound silly but
what I think it's done for me and when I
see why it works for others it actually
liberates you into not thinking that you
have to make these perfect decisions I
don't think I make any good
decisions I'm being serious like I I
just think I'm making decisions to the
best of my ability at that moment and
sometimes it's going to be very good and
sometimes it's not going to be but
you're putting too much pressure there's
listen to the questions we're just very
good at putting pressure on ourselves to
acheve achieve something that's not
achievable for
what actually you know what based on the
questions and then I'll I'll let you ask
a second I have one very good
recommendation if you can find yourself
in the next year or two to have a
conversation with somebody extremely
elderly that is not a family member of
yours do
it maybe you can even have like a
grandparents Exchange
program I really mean this I think that
the thing that I do well is I my parents
always told me stories as a child that
when I was three and four I'd go outside
and I'd hang out with 90-year-old people
and like genuinely like hang out with
them and I always thought it was a funny
story and then as I've gotten older I'm
like oh okay like I think I do believe
in this old soul stuff like you're
attracted to certain energies I think
all I'm doing now is telling you the
things that 90y olds know I think you
need more of that in your life like like
you know I think the way to attack truly
having fomo is flipping it and
understanding everything is fomo
everything's in play you're missing out
on everything all the time which then
will make you comfortable with
it what was the second part yeah like
how how open should you really be at the
work it's like how transparent should
you be as transparent as your bosses
allow right the answer to that is like
at Vayner me at my company I can tell
you that people are pretty transparent
because I've established in 15 years
that I don't fire people if they insult
me there's a lot of places where people
get fired for the smallest things
because the leadership is either
insecure or traditional I think the
reality is is there's a lot of ways to
think about it the literal answer to
your question is as much as the
leadership has allowed you to be the
deeper answer is as much as you want to
be because do you want to be in a place
where you don't feel like you can be
transparent on the flip side I think
some of the modern thoughts that we all
have like the world works on non full
transparency you know privacy is
valuable too like holding in certain
thoughts has value as well so I think
what the world struggles with is
balance and so you know I think I think
what I'm worried about with the word
transparency is that a lot of people
don't realize that they're weaponizing
it for
judgment I I also think to Gary comes
from a context at V the media and how he
believes that it's the role of the
leader or the manager to make the
employees them
safe so safety is a very big thing in
leadership so in in the Arab business
culture it's not that the in the
American Business culture good news in
the American Business culture it's not
common yeah but just like that feeling
of can we be transparent like there's
always this feeling like should we share
or not share should we do the full way
or not so there's always that feeling so
the way I face living and working here
for 2 years by the way if you
interviewed all 2,000 employees of V
media they tell you the same thing they
have it better than everyone else but
when you are an employee you're always
thinking is this good or bad for me for
my job that's just the reality of like
it's also being a public figure I
literally am thinking it every time that
I'm one sentence away from having a
problem right it's just it's the real
like it's the way the world Works to me
to me I think the the bigger question is
are you building the relationships that
allows your transparency to
land right the key to that question is
you don't want to be transparent for the
sake of transparency you want to be
transparent for the sake of trying to
make the thing better to me building
relationships with leaders
contemporaries your direct reports
parallel to you above you below you I
think we need more relationship building
in the world and I think that's a thing
to be thinking about if I could just
build
addition it's also about trust you want
to feel that the person you're being
transparent with you can trust them with
your either vulnerability and and to the
point you can't form trust without
having a real relationship right so this
kind of all hand in hand and I think
that's it's a really good question and
it's also something that I feel like and
Gary's always uh talking about being and
it's not either or it's always and like
can you trust and develop the
relationship so that you have that sense
of trust I think it's important
it's a it's a it's a forever challenge
for everybody it's a huge challenge
around the world it's you know as we
travel the world as I travel the world
the thing I'm most interested in is
cultures subcultures Traditions every
single part of the world thinks their
part is different than everybody else
but all of it ladds to the same human
truth you know because you all know this
there's Saudi Arabia then there let's
start even higher there's the Middle
East then there's Saudi Arabia then
there your company acts different than
the company next door then it's your
actual boss is even different than some
of the bosses in the company there's
always more context and I think that's
what you need to be thinking about your
the answer is based on the relationship
and the DNA of the people you want to
have that conversation with but back to
who you're sitting next to and a good
theme for
everyone words are
powerful and using words words is a
really important thing most people have
unhappy professional careers because
they don't use their
words